[Music]  metro police reflecting on use of force  incidents in the department's most  recent five-year report that was coming  in last year metro officers shot 10  people six of them died that is the  lowest number of incidents in the last  five years let's go to non-deadly use of  force the department reporting its  highest numbers over five years 941  that's when police use a taser a k-9  officer in those cases also on the list  is the type of neck restraint in 2017 it  was used 31 times last year the  department reporting zero incidents this  comes after a change in policy that only  allows an officer to use it if he or she  fears for their life